verehrte sie dem publikum wir sind
zurück in berlin
heute ist der neunte november 2016 vor
wenigen stunden hat donald trump die
wahl zum neuen us präsidenten gewonnen
und die emotionen sind außer sich manche
leute sind total begeistert und freuen
sich manche leute sind total fertig und
traurig und deshalb ist unser thema
heute wie ist deine stimmung heute
losgehen
hallo wie geht's euch seid ihr alle gut
drauf die stimmung heute morgen die ist
großartig die stimmung ja gute laune
riesig hervorragend morgen ist guter
laune aufgewacht
ja ich bin für eine putzfrau geweckt
worden
im zimmer hotel feuerwerk der guten
laune geht durch europa was sagt
deutschland ich weiß nicht was
deutschland sagt ich bin entspannt wie
jeden tag für mich ein tag wie jeder
andere und ich genieße die sonne gestern
war es traurig weil es bedeckt war heute
ist schön mal die sonne scheint wieso
die sonne scheint auch heute ja aber die
wahlen amerika ist nicht so gut dass die
stimmung in deutschland war heute nur
deutsch klasse geschrieben und da fragen
wir also über geredet
wir waren richtig fertig und das recht
es gibt auch gute nachrichten der
eurokurs steigt erst aus ist ein good
news this morning for example eurostat
die sonne
die engländer sind nicht mehr die
größten sektoren nachdenklich mit dem
eine kleine gedanke wahrscheinlich in
amerika aktuelle war vermutlich mal
passiert erstmal gut dann hab ich
irgendwie und danach war ich dann
verwirrt weil dann habe ich irgendwie
alles mitbekommen
und was soll ich sagen seit immer die
frage wird es so werden wie es alle
jetzt momentan habe vorhersagen wird es
vielleicht ganz anders
wie ist die stimmung sehr schönes wetter
ist okay mein zwinger war jetzt
denn anders gehabt aber wenn es das
beste draus machen muss mal gucken wie
ist die stimmung sehr schwierig ist die
wahl bis vier uhr morgens mitverfolgt
und anfang haben nicht gedacht dass
trump gewinn wird und was jetzt bis
jetzt drauf wie fühlst du dich
mischung aus schock und
leider ist es also schwer zu sagen ich
bin ist es schade jetzt ruhig mal den
martin an
mal sehen was der an martin die an
martin mal den malina alles klar im bh
du bist kein leid für sie samen ihr wir
fragen gerade die menschen nach der
stimmung ein feuerwerk der guten laune
geht durch die welt wie ist es bei dir
hallo klaus wie sich die stimmung in den
nächsten wochen noch entwickeln wird
jetzt so wie wir nach dem wechsel erst
mal realisieren wie es jetzt weitergehen
wird damit versuchen zu arbeiten
schadensbegrenzung und irgendwann
akzeptieren dass man mit einem gewissen
herrn trump auch irgendwann zusammen
arbeiten muss ja klar ich wollte mal
wissen wie es die stimmung heute richtig
was los hier auch muss ich echt sagen
also den ganzen tag mit einem grinsen
gearbeitet klaus er sicher bin ich auch
dabei
und das macht mir gerade die gute laune
herrlich ist das
die stimmung ist schlecht würde ich
sagen wenn ich hier die fresse von trump
sehe dann muss ich sagen mach ich mir
wirklich sorgen in die westliche
demokratie also ich hab fast die ganze
nacht die wahl geguckt und war
schockiert wirklich bin ein bisschen
sprachlos jetzt wie ist die stimmung
sehr nachdenklich ja also nicht somit zu
guter laune auf gestand wie ich
unbedingt nehmen obwohl die sonne
scheint obwohl die sonne scheint trägt
aber zur erhebung der laune auf jeden
fall skala von 1 bis 10 groß steht das
gute laune warum meter gerade das
persönliche mittlerweile schon wieder
über 5 ja und das unversöhnliche das
nachdenklich über 34 geht nachher kein
schlimmer
in diesen feierstunde des glücks wie
fühlt man sich da depressiv also ich
finds nicht so zum feiern ich gesagt nee
nicht so keine party vorbereitet für von
elfter elfter aber nicht wie heute
findet am 11 11
statt für die zuschauer die das nicht
wissen da wird feierlich der karneval
eröffnet am elften elften um 11 uhr 11
wie es angela merkel heute morgen
aufgewacht
ich glaube mit dem linken fuß ja was hat
sie gefühlt dabei ich glaube sie hat den
tiefen schmerz gefühlt wie jeden morgen
das weiß ich nicht wie war die stimmung
heute morgen im bundeskanzleramt ging
die rakete der guten laune durch die
decke schön beschissen
die haben ja alle mit namen anders
gerechnet oder wollen sondern lieber ich
glaube nicht dass die sich gefreut haben
darüber weil ja auch gar nicht wissen
wer ist das soll die mit der wille
clinton sehr bewusst mit der die kinder
schon lange und haben auch kontakte
schon ein meriva schon mal da ja und
weisheit wo berlin ist wie es angela
merkel heute morgen aufgewacht hatte die
gute laune
justina begrüßen euch das interview
gesehen und denke mir jetzt ganz
diplomatisch gemacht und wir müssen uns
alle das beste das beste draus machen
müssen wir gucken was passiert was wird
passieren ja kein hellseher aber ich
denke es wird nicht so schlimm wie alle
sagen aber sage ich mal waren jetzt
beide kandidaten jetzt nicht die
optimale wahl aber muss mal schauen wann
war die stimmung besser nachdem brad
pitt oder nach der jobwahl in
deutschland nach dem wechsel woher ich
meine es zwar schade dass der grund
europäische gedanke nur verloren geht
aber die usa hat man immer noch so seine
hoffnungen gehabt und vielleicht mehr
hoffnungen reingesteckt als man am ende
dann raus bekommen hat mit dem guten
früh aufgestanden von ungläubigkeit bis
zu entsetzen und untergangsszenarien war
nicht alles dabei
in der schule war eigentlich immer was
genau ist denn das die united states war
die laune besser nachdem wechselt oder
heute morgen ich würde nach dem wechsel
war noch ein stück besser sagen sie
jetzt überrascht
äußerlich bleibt abzuwarten wer wird ja
immer präsidenten auch angela merkel
vorbereitet auf diese situation als ihr
job dass sie darauf vorbereitet ist also
denke ich mental war sie vorbereitet
emotional weiß ich nicht ja liebe leute
das war unsere episode für heute mit dem
thema wie ist deine stimmung
er hat gesehen die stimmung hier ist
sehr unterschiedlich aber die meisten
leute in berlin
hier auf der straße waren tatsächlich
eher kritisch gegenüber
donald trump und hatten eher schlechte
laune das liegt daran dass tatsächlich
die meisten deutschen donald trump er
nicht unterstützen es gibt umfragen die
sagen 80 bis 90 prozent der deutschen
mögen deutschland nicht also seid bitte
nicht überrascht und wirft uns nicht vor
dass wir ja nur eine bestimmte anzahl
von leuten gezeigt haben denn das ist
tatsächlich so wenn man hier über die
straße geht findet man wenige die donald
trump unterstützen
wir selber haben natürlich auch eine
meinung manchmal hat man das vielleicht
ein bisschen gesehen aber wir
unterhalten uns auch mit menschen aus
allen verschiedenen lagern wir sagen
hier
wir waren selber auch bei einer donald
trump rallye in den usa und haben dort
mit leuten gesprochen und jetzt möchten
wir auch mit euch darüber sprechen
schreibt uns in die kommentare wie eure
stimmung war benutzt unser vokabular von
heute und trainierte vokabular und bitte
vergesst nicht dass ihr dabei freut
nicht bleibt und sachlich ihr könnt auch
witze machen aber nicht böse
die anderen leute beleidigen das mögen
wir nicht in den kommentaren bleibt
freundlich und diskutiert mit uns wir
freuen uns bis zur nächsten woche